the singing competition show is back and  Monday's premier proof things are more  competitive than ever especially amongst  the judges Adam Levine Blake Shelton and  newcomers Alicia Keys and Miley Cyrus  I'm ready to share my knowledge my  experience I think use it very seriously  is what I love the most among the blind  audition highlights 28 year old ally  Caldwell who sparked a lot of emotion  and some feisty conversation how many  seasons you once i receive it with i  take my leave the episode had plenty of  girl power but interestingly team alicia  so far is only men jason warrior Dave  moisten and cristian cuevas  teen Blake started off strong with  Sundance head Dana Harper and Gabe  Brassard while team Adam is shaping up  with 16 year old jazz crooner Riley  Elmore  which team is your favorite so far tell  us on Twitter at et now